all right Rosie Rosie uh where you from
originally where' you grow up Los
Angeles California Los Angeles yeah tell
me about your family you had Mom and Dad
Mom and Dad yeah I had both parents
they're both born and raised Mexico they
came over here and then they met had us
I'm a I'm the youngest of four yeah how
would you describe your
childhood uh a little
confusing my my earliest memory was my
mom telling me not to be left alone with
my
dad I didn't understand why then of
course I do now but that that was the
start of your mom told you not to be
left alone with my dad really you know
if she left the room I should be right
behind her you know that was that's what
she told me yeah
so early on everything was fine like
aside from like the the abuse with my
dad um my my mom was she's very quiet
you know she's not very um affectionate
but for like you know Christmas
birthdays you know she always provided
we always had food clothes
but we we were financially struggling a
couple times but she was really good at
hiding
it our first house um I believe we went
bankrupt a couple times she had a lot of
money problems I feel like she was very
depressed and angry she has her own
trauma
so and my dad didn't help at all to you
know he's a typical Hispanic man he
didn't speak English but he was abusive
to her
mentally sometimes
physically when she was pregnant with my
youngest sister he actually pulled a gun
out on her and threaten to kill her in
front of her my mom's mom my
grandma Yeah you know growing up there
was always arguing you know that was
normal
um yeah I grew up pretty pretty angry
you
know you you mentioned there was abuse
with your dad but you didn't just didn't
tell me what kind of abuse
um I I have really bad well not memory
but like with the trauma it kind of it's
funny how it blocks out some parts like
the first experience I had with him you
know um my mom and him would talk a lot
on their bed in Spanish and I would
always eeve drop and like try to listen
to what they were saying um so one time
she had left the room and I remember
being small like I could barely climb on
top of their
bed and I remember the shirt I was
wearing it's like a little white shirt
with the little the little bow ties in
the front and right when she left the
room you know his eyes changed you know
I recognize those eyes now but you know
I didn't know what it was then and my
mom used to give me like back scratches
and like rubs so I can go to sleep I
called it like tickles I like that and
he asked me to get in the bed with him I
you know I didn't think anything of it
so I got into the bed with him and you
know that's what it's I was facing laid
down that's how it started you know he
was doing that and then he he turned me
around and he lived up my shirt he was
like tickling my
stomach and then you know then he
started touching my chest and like
touching my nipples
and I remember I remember him you know
lifting up the blanket and he told me to
go under the blanket and you know I was
small I was like right by his stomach
maybe and that's that's when I don't
remember anything else a lot of like
situations like that I I can remember
the beginning and the end like I
remember after was getting under the
blanket and I remember being sweaty and
from being under the blanket and I
remember just jumping off the bed he
told told me where are you going and I
said oh I'll be right back and I just I
left the room there's a lot of
situations like that like my mom would
always leave the the kitchen light on
like a little um NightLight and I used
to be scared of the dark you know I
would pee the bed a lot sign of sexual
abuse but um this time I had two other
sisters and this time they slept on the
top bunk we all shared one
room um so this night I remember my back
was facing the door and the light peaked
in a little my mom would leave the door
open a little and I could see the light
you know reflect on the wall where I was
facing
and I remember seeing the door open you
know through the light and I I thought
it was my mom I didn't want to get in
trouble so you know I I was still laying
still closed my eyes to pretend to go to
sleep and I kept my eyes closed the
whole time I know I felt someone sit on
the bed with me and they took the
blanket off I remember being cold and
they pulled my pants my pants down and
then I felt cold hands you know pulling
I remember feeling my underwear get you
taken off of me and then again I just
blacked out I don't remember
anything but a lot of it was like that
like more of the serious stuff I don't
know how far it went
like have you talked to a therapist
about yeah I'm in therapy right now but
um he had told me something like um
you know even if you do remember is that
going to benefit you in any way cuz I
told him you know I I I'm almost angry
that I can't remember because I don't
know I want to know almost how like how
far it went you know I don't like
not you know not not knowing what
happened to
me but yeah did your sisters get the
same treatment um my oldest sister
didn't I have a sister who's a year
older than me and when she was a baby
about 2 to three years old I didn't know
this at the time until I was way older
you know I don't know the extent of it
either but there was a report on him you
know my mom found her shaking and I
don't know if she was raped or you know
but there was a case and my mom dropped
it because she she had asked my sister
when she was a 2 three years old you
know do you forgive Daddy and she said
yes so that's what she told me she
forgave her you know I when I C the only
reason I came out I did end up coming
out and telling my mom about what
happened to me because my my oldest
sister I was 17 at the time my sister
was
about she's like 5 years older than me I
can't really do the math but she had her
first baby in 2019 so in 2020 around
July she was she was a little bit older
you know she's a baby she could barely
sit up now and I still haven't said
anything that's happened to me and I
remember seeing my dad hold her
baby and the look that look came back
that he would give theab
baby so we had went on this like trip to
see my aunt in Bakersfield and I
remember on the way home I couldn't
stopped thinking about it and my sister
and the baby and my mom were in the car
and I just brought it up I told her you
know there's something I have to tell
you and I had told her you know like I
don't know I don't remember much but you
know this is this is what's been going
on and it didn't stop even when I was
older I was just it it was less frequent
but you know there was times where like
my mom would be in the room and he would
come home from work and he would come
over me
sorry he would kiss kiss on my neck and
like grope me and like in front of her
and I would tell him stop touching me in
front of my mom and she would turn
around and he would stop and he would
she'll be like what are you doing like
my mom would just think he was hugging
me and she I grew up so angry I didn't
like anyone touching me she thought like
he was just hugging me and she would
tell him like leave her alone like what
are you doing and he would just laugh
this his [__] laugh is still in my
head all the time that he would do it in
front of her without with like right in
front of her so when I had told um I had
told um my mom what happened you know
she was she was crying because you know
it happened to my sister and it was
going on with me and my my oldest sister
was crying too you know they were
hurting for me and my mom promised me
that I would never have to see him
again and
sorry
you know she promised me
and and she did end up kicking him out
for like a month and she was still
seeing him and it turned out like he he
didn't feel good and she went to the
hospital with my dad
and he had some sore of tumor in his
stomach
and he was sick after after leaving and
I remember her coming home and my sister
who's a year older than me she was
living with her boyfriend she wasn't
there but my oldest sister who wasn't
affected and my brother who were there
you know were all there my mom's crying
and she says I have something to tell
you guys you
know uh your Dad's sick like I don't
know if it was cancer I don't remember
but I remember the first thing I thought
was thank God like after all this time
you know he's finally getting his karma
you know and I didn't at all I was like
I was almost happy and I see like my
brother and my sister crying and my
mom's crying and I'm like why are you
guys crying over this piece of
[__] and she told and she looked at me
and she said you know what this means
and I was like what are you talking
about she said he's coming back you know
I can't I can't let him be out on the
street and I was angry you know like he
gets sick and then he gets the prince's
treatment of just coming back
it wasn't fair and I didn't have support
like my oldest sibling and my sister of
course they wanted him back and my
sister who also dealt with the same
things to me she was already out of the
house
like I felt
alone I
felt small and before he came back my
sister ended up moving back in with me
and we confronted my mom you know we
said why are you allowing back here and
it was in front of my oldest sister too
who wasn't affected and I told her I
basically blamed her and I said you know
this is your fault this happened to me
because you allowed him back into the
house after what he did to my
sister and you thought you were safe and
he did the exact same thing maybe even
more to me cuz it was just one time with
my sister
but and my oldest
sister sorry
no I told her this is your fault and my
oldest sister got up and she's like
don't you talk to our mom that way she's
cussing me out you know she's like
you're so disrespectful you don't you
don't deserve to tell her that cuz I
told her she was a bad
mom and my oldest sister defending her
and me and my sister are just looking at
each other like what the [__] is wrong
with
them you know I spoke up to protect her
child my brother has a daughter too you
know I did it for them you know I would
have never said
anything
sorry
so so
2020 up until this year I had to I had
to live with this man and I told my mom
like my concerns you know I don't feel
safe here and she tells me just lock
your
door nothing's going to
happen and I was supposed to graduate in
2020 I was still in school I had a job I
was
working
and living like that I didn't graduate
high school I dropped out you know Co
hit I stopped
working I was really
depressed I slept so
much
and my mom wasn't nice to me anymore you
know before she had brought him back in
I remember seeing her sneak out and you
know I've never I'm not disrespectful at
all I defend my mom with my life and
this was like the time where she started
cussing at me and disrespecting me like
I saw her leaving the house once and I
knew she was going to go see my dad and
I had asked her like where are you going
and she told me to shut the [__] up to
mind my
business I don't
know I love my mom even to this day you
know
but like during that time when I wasn't
working or going to school you know she
obviously she was paying for everything
and I guess that's her way of showing
love but that doesn't make me feel
loved sorry how did your
dad how was your dad
now he's still the same he treats her
bad um
you
know my sister and my brother still
bring the kids around
him
um I I would never stay home you know my
mom was pretty strict with curfews and I
wasn't working you know I didn't have
money to go out but I would go out at
every chance I got whether it was a
friend's
house whether it was a random dude's
house like I didn't care and that's what
my mom thought the problem was me living
there you know the curfew that wasn't
what it was
about I started doing drugs I was doing
psychedelics Molly I was doing Molly
every [__] day even when I was there
at home I would never sleep and she
caught me once and she said you're not
sleeping you think I'm stupid I know
you're doing something and I was like no
I'm not doing
anything and no matter how much I would
tell her like you know or it's this
that's hurting me she told me you know
tell me the truth like what's going on
with you I'll tell her and she'll be
like oh we'll get you a therapist like
you'll be fine and it's like I no matter
how much therapy I have even living
there it's not going to help me when my
abuser is in the same home I don't care
if I don't see him often you know I'm
making food and I hear him opening the
door I run to my room so I don't have to
look at him cuz he still has the balls
to look at you or me in my eye you
know like I'm uncomfortable with myself
now
like would comment on my
body and he was creep like even my
that's what makes me upset about with my
older sister is like we couldn't wear
shorts in the
house because he would
look and my mom would tell us that we
confronted him you know we would all
come to my mom at different ages like
he's still looking at us and in front of
her too like it wasn't a glance like you
walked and his head was turning [__]
looking at your ass like it was
ridiculous
and she did nothing he said that we were
lying all the time like I remember I
couldn't even take a nap like I love
sleeping and this was like in Middle
School almost I remember sleeping in
shorts it was hot and I can't even do
that without this [__] weirdo
creeping in and I wake up and he's
[__] staring at me like looking
through the door
like
it's
ridiculous he likes scaring me he was
like if I
slept the way he would wake me up is
dragging me by my feet like towards him
and obviously I'm waking up [__] like
don't you know my mom thinks money's
power like she knows living alone is
hard
and I
left like once or twice for a couple
days and then she begs me please please
come
back
but you know this time I didn't really
care where I ended
up I I was so fed up with
her and being there I left with nothing
no money no nothing you know I was
grateful for my friend Michaela my best
friend she let me stay at her house for
a couple
months
and from there I found a nice program
hope of the valley there a
shelter so I am homeless but that's
where I'm staying right now and they
help so much with education therapy even
job
employment food
clothes and I've never felt more free
than than being there and you know I
thought that's that's how life was that
I had to endure that you you know I
didn't have money so I had to stay there
and that's not how it is you
know my dad thought he he had all the
balls in the house because he had money
you know he was the provider and I think
that's why my mom would Shing him around
all the
time how old are you now I'm 20 turning
November still super young yeah
do you know any history of what your
what your mom went through or your dad
when they were
young my dad um no I don't know he
doesn't really talk about his past much
I know his dad was hard on him but my
mom
uh her and her sister
ironically uh they had a her oldest
brother they're family of seven big
family and there're the two youngest
daughters
um her abuser was her
brother and I would expect her to know
better you know she also dealt with him
she was really young and again her
family for both of the sisters turned
their backs you know didn't say anything
you know he was welcomed all the time
and even growing up you know it was
pushed aside I I would we would sleep
over his house and
like even
growing up
um I didn't understand why like I I
heard it mentioned a few times and it
would be you know shushed and my mom
lost her dad
in uh
2019 and I remember there was problems
because all
this there was it's a long story but he
was in a retirement home or like you
know nursing home and he was assaulted
and he had a brain bleeding like a
hemorrhage thing
um and they were suing the place and of
course my mom was the only one that
visited her and then all her brothers
came and they were um trying to you know
take power over him to find out what
happened to the money cuz it was all
about
money
and my mom's brother the
abuser he has a wife a new wife and she
doesn't know anything about this so at
the hospital
you know some of them don't get along
and it was tossed out you know they
called him a rapist and his wife was
there
and it was funny it was funny at the
time cuz I don't like this man and he
always he's he's a he's a man of God now
you know he's in church every day but
it's sad how common how common all of
this is and even my cousins like none of
them even knew about this like I told a
few of them they're like my parents
never told me it's like they all know
and we're still going to family
gatherings and having you
know it's just wrong and my mom still
heard about it today you know like when
there's family events and stuff she goes
oh I don't know why they're inviting him
you know my her younger sister she took
action you know she separated
herself and you know she talks for
herself and she's way more confident and
my
mom I feel like my mom is is just so
used to being set aside that she doesn't
fight for herself anymore and sometimes
when she did mention it even to my my
other sister would be like how are you
bothered by he's going to be there you
know you have to see his face but you're
bringing your husband around
us and she would always talk about
forgiveness like you need to forgive him
he's your father and I'm like okay well
you need to forgive your brother then
because he's your brother right it makes
no sense to
me it's disgusting
what are your plans from here on
out I don't know right now there a
program I'm in they help me get an
apartment with my sister I'm really
thankful
for
um I just need a job and I hope to
figure out you know what I want to do
career-wise
still going to go to therapy after after
I leave the shelter but right now I'm
just taking it day by
day you're angry at both your
parents yeah and it's kind of sad that
I'm more angry at my mom than my
abuser cuz I just want to be
heard and I I feel
like like that's all I want from my you
know my other two siblings said my
sister told me you know he doesn't
remember so you know get over it and she
denied saying that to me and and my
other sister heard it and we she's like
you know you did say that to me she
never apologized for it she said no I
didn't and she's like when I had moved
out she told me oh you know I see that
your F your friends are more than family
you know good luck with your friends
let's see how long that lasts you know
and I'm like I'd rather have no family
you know you guys are you guys are all
mean to me you guys don't understand me
and you get upset when I turn or I leave
away from the people who are causing me
so much pain you know my friends or the
few that I have have supported me more
than any of you you know my best
friend's mom Michaela her name is
Molly she I'm very thankful for her you
know she's like the mother I never had
basically so so kind she's she's a
strong woman too I'm just thankful you
know for the few people that I have that
you know they they help me
get get through all of this I'm not 100%
now
but day by
day what emotions are you dealing with
most probably anger or regret
I feel very angry with myself cuz you
know I get depressed a lot and I feel
like I I use the past as an excuse like
I don't want to go to work today cuz I'm
tired you know I let a lot of opportuni
slide because I feel almost lazy you
know I can get my GED or do a high set
test you know at the place I'm at right
now but I have zero motivation for
anything what are your
regrets I regret not
um I have a lot of regrets but the main
too is not speaking up sooner about what
was happening to me because my sister
had to stay in silence
too and maybe it would have changed
something maybe it wouldn't but I wish I
said something so we we didn't have to
go on for so
long in
silence I felt like I basically was her
voice too you know they did the same
thing to her it was brushed off
and and ever since I came out and you
know told them what happened to me she
she took the step too and finally cut
him off we haven't spoken to him in
almost 3 years and my sister is not in
contact with any of them right now she
has a lot of anger and I feel bad
because you know it was probably
suppressed from all this time and I had
to be that example and I feel bad I wish
I said something
sooner what's your biggest fear
now probably being a
parent I I was pregnant in August
um obviously my situation I'm not ideal
to be a a mom right now you know I'm
homeless so I didn't go through with it
and that's one of my regrets you know I
felt like I still don't have motivation
for myself
but it was was actually excited at one
point you know I I was debating what to
do but you know I I just thought it
wasn't best for me right now but that I
do regret that I felt
like not to be cliche but I really felt
like that was a sign for me you know to
have motivation at least for someone
because I know I'd be a great mom but
I'm scared of that and I felt like that
was a sign for me you know but again I
let that go and I regret that
Rie what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from all
of this I was dreading this
question
um I don't
know I really don't know I I was
thinking about this for a lot and I
don't have you're still in the middle of
it too I don't have an answer it's all
right sorry like wish you all the luck
in the world you deserve it thank
you I think getting away from home is
probably the best thing you can do yeah
I'm happy I'm
free something good will come your
way I hope so thank you all righty thank
you
that